I am a card-carrying member of the
market system and I'm here to tell you
it was the market system that failed it
was not the government a huge percentage
of them of the bad loans came out of
companies that when fact were regulated
and were encouraged to do subprime
lending where were the regulator's
during this period they were gone they
were gone there were nowhere to be found
the Federal Reserve helped create the
housing bubble by flooding the financial
system with money and by setting the
short-term interest rate well below the
marxist natural rate it's not
government's heavy hand and overbearing
relationship to the markets that caused
the crisis it's the lack of oversight on
the markets that caused the crisis it
wasn't a light hand of God was the hand
of government pounding on your head
trying to make you make subprime
mortgages welcome to this sixth debate
of the third season of the so forum at
the sub-culture theater in downtown
Manhattan I'm Jean Epstein director of
the Sola forum we're a special monthly
debate series that features topics of
special interest to libertarians and
aims to enhance social and professional
ties within New York City's libertarian
community we're partnered with Reason
magazine and presenting these debates
and you can catch audio and video of all
our events on Reason TV this is an
Oxford style debate in which the
audience
initially votes for against or undecided
on the resolution and then again after
the debate is over whoever moves the
vote in his or her favor is declared the
winner
go into Soho vote calm to cast your
initial vote you'll find the tonight's
resolution reads the financial crisis of
2008 was caused mainly by government
induced distortion of markets rather
than caused mainly by intrinsic market
failure here to defend the resolution
John Allison John please come to the
stage
i speaking for the negative on the
resolution
mark sandy mark please come to the stage
now we're going to start the PowerPoint
presentation for the first time bear
with us we think it'll go well John
Allison you have 15 minutes to defend
the resolution please take the podium
John good evening I was a
longest-serving CEO of a major financial
institution when the recent Great
Recession occurred my company BB&T went
through the crisis without a single
quarterly loss
I was also leading BB&T lending business
in the early 1980s and CEO and there
only 90s when the economy experienced
other major Corrections I have a unique
insider's perspective on the recent
financial crisis I served on the
committee the Financial Services
Roundtable for nine years trying to do
something about Fannie Mae and Freddie
Mac which are quite appropriately called
government-sponsored enterprises it was
a mathematical certainty and that Fannie
and Freddie were going broke from their
enormous purchases of high-risk
mortgages we met with congressmen on
numerous occasions including congressman
Barney Frank
I called Barney the evil one because he
actually is smart unlike most of the
others but possibly because Fannie and
Freddie were major financial
contributors the Democratic Party and
because Barney had a religious
conviction that all Americans should be
homeowners he was willing to cheerfully
behead anyone that might stand in the
way that's Mike began by drawing a
distinction between two related but
fairly separate questions about the
busting housing bubble of 2008 first
what causes second once it did occur why
did it trigger the worst recession since
the Great Depression of the 1930s on the
second question while the toxic
mortgages that choked the financial
system were bound to bring an economic
recession
I believe that the government's reaction
the crisis both prolong the downturn and
increases severity but in this debate
I'm here to focus only on the first
question what caused it in the first
place to defend the resolution the
financial crisis of 2008 was called
mainly by government induced distortion
of markets rather than caused mainly by
intrinsic market failure let's start
with a government entity that has the
greatest power to distort markets the
Federal Reserve the Federal Reserve
helped create the housing bubble by
flooding the financial system with money
and by setting the short-term interest
rate well below the marxist natural rate
the best estimate that I've seen of a
difference between the interest rate the
Fed artificially imposed and the markets
natural rate comes from a peer-reviewed
paper co-authored by monetary colonists
George Celgene this chart tracks the
main findings it's the difference
between the actual interest rate
dictated by the Fed and what economists
estimate to be the natural market rate
based on changes in price inflation and
in productivity the horizontal line on
the chart traces the neutral zone with
the market interest rate in the fates
right feds rate converged monetary
policy becomes loose when the
fluctuating line cuts below the neutral
line and you can see it starting in year
2000 monetary policy soon became even
looser than it was in the seventies and
it's no coincidence that starting the
year 2000 the bubble that had already
been forming in the price of phones
really begin to take off the next chart
hopefully comes from Nobel prize-winning
economist Robert Shiller and it's based
on an index number that adjusts the
average houses price for improvements in
quality from overall price inflation it
shows many bubbles formed in the 70s and
80s and also it shows that from 1996 to
2000 a very similar many meebo mini
bubble had began to form but it's
instead of receding as it had in the
past the price started to jump to new
highs by 2001 and 2002 quoting Shiller
the number-one boom occurred from
February 1997 to October 1996 when house
prices a real house prices increased 70
percent from 1997 to December 2003 real
house prices increased 45% while I was
the looseness in Fed policy having a
specialty impact on housing prices whose
monetary policy has been referred to as
the punchbowl but gets markets drunk in
this case the government offered a
second punch bowl of the housing segment
starting them in 1980s in Occident
it orchestrated a massive effort to
boost homeownership mainly implemented
by the giant government-sponsored
enterprises Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac
in a recent article Mark Zandi has
actually summarized this story pretty
well he wrote that it was the effect of
the GSEs Fannie and Freddie to quote
expand lending to historically
underserved families that caused the
crisis Marx continues the government
requirement that Fannie and Freddie help
expand lending to these families calls
them to inappropriately lower their
lending standards in the lead-up to the
crisis which drove other private
mortgage lenders to do same and created
the downward spiral of unsustainable
debt that led to the housing collapse
I should add however the mark calls this
story mythology and even pronation I
regardless story is quite true the
government's actions happen in plain
sight when President Clinton announced
his national home ownership strategy in
June 1995 he spoke of the need to make
it easy for people to own their own
homes in 1996 of the partisan I'm
housing and urban development begin
setting annual goals for the proportion
of mortgages of low and income families
that Fanny and Fanny were required to
buy the goal was increased each year
rising from 40 percent in 1996 to 50
percent by 2001 in a press release dated
July 1999 President Clinton announced
that the homeownership rate is at an
all-time high with more than 66 percent
of all American families owning their
homes and reported that goals of Fetty
and families purchase and mortgage were
being raised quote over and above the
one point nine trillion dollars in
mortgages for twenty 1.1 million
families that would have been generated
the current goals have been retained the
policies continued under Clinton
successor George W Bush a 2004 press
least from Fannie Mae bolted to having
provided over three trillion dollars in
funds for over 28 million underserved
families over the course of previous
decades these policies were having
affect the climate homeownership rate
shown in this chart reflects that a man
pressure was trailing house prices even
higher as this chart shows the home rate
ownership rate had actually climbed to a
record high of 66 percent by the second
quarter of 1998 even earlier than Fred
and Clinton had thought by
fourth-quarter 2003 in a jump to sixty
eight point six percent peaking at 69
percent in second quarter 2004 before it
began to fall from 1997 through 2003
Freddie and Fannie alone purchase 1.7
trillion dollars worth of high-risk
mortgages that doesn't include active
participation high-risk mortgages by
government agencies that include the
Federal Housing Administration and the
abettor Veterans Administration
it also doesn't include the rigorous
enforcement of the Community
Reinvestment Act and other community
lending deals which require that private
lending institution give mortgages to
lower-income families I emphasize that
all this happened in the period leading
up to 2003 for a special reason a few
years ago I had the privilege of sitting
next to mark on a panel about the
financial crisis and hearing his main
arguments he repeats the same arguments
in the article I just recorded for him
published in September mark tries to
refute the idea that government policy
was crit
crucial and creating the housing bill by
citing data from 2004 through 2006 but
by focusing on 2004 to 2006
Marcus placed himself in the position of
a guy who walks into the theater in the
last reel of the movie
this chart released by Federal Housing
regulators reveals what happened before
mark arrived to the scene in a tributes
to each major set of institutions from
1990 through 2007
the mortgages that were actually used to
purchase homes in its year and it
actually under states this year
attributable to Freddie and Fannie
notice the chart has a breakout for
private-label securities these are bonds
that are backed by
who of mortgages holders of these bonds
receive their payments out of the
payments made on the mortgages Fannie
and Freddie routinely bought massive
amounts of Hope mortgages and packaged
them in this form and the private sector
did the same and and in fact fede and
Fannie bought hundreds of billions of
dollars worth of these private-label
securities to help meet their affordable
housing goals imposed by the Department
of Housing and Development
but since the chart doesn't reflect
these acquisitions the percentage share
on this chart over States this year of
purchase mortgages held by the private
sector and under states this year held
by Freddie and Fannie but the chart
still shows that in the crucial years
from 1997 to 2003 the combined share of
the Fannie and Freddie plus out of the
FHA and Veterans Administration was
always greater than 60% of all mortgages
this with this commanding share they
drove the market in in dollar terms the
value of these purchases mortgages more
than double for four and forty billion
in 1997 to 886 billion in 2003 before
leveling off the Rainer went to the
private section combined share banks and
other lenders this institution plus the
issues of private-label securities from
1997 to 19 2003 the private sector share
with almost always was was always less
than 40 percent it shear started to rise
into fairly 2004 but barely exceeded 50
prints sent in the single year 2005 and
it's mentioned even these figures are
overstated because so many private-label
securities were bought by Freddie and
Fannie mark should read the January 2019
working paper called Margus mortgage
rich since nineteen tiny from which I
took these figures analysts with a
federal agency that issued this report
say quite clearly we show that mortgage
risks that are already risen in the
1990s planting the seeds of the
financial crisis will before the actual
event why did the private sector get
more heavily involved in late 2003 the
price bubble government policies they
created lute lured this in this chart on
12-month half price insulin increases
mainly in California reals a key factor
notice
by June 2000 when the bubble had already
taken off prices begin to rise ten
percent a year and and by December 2003
by sixteen point four percent now you
say give them now you gave a mortgage to
a high-risk debtor with a down payment
of just three percent if the debtor
can't meet the payments you can always
help him reef in the henson thumb will
be more for at least ten percent a year
or you can foreclose and sell the house
for more than you know now I had two
other factors that were fueling the
mania it's mentioned Fanny and Fanny
we're buying up whole mortgages and
private mortgage-backed securities by
the hundreds of billions of dollars so
the private financial institution Pleet
believed they could always sell their
toxic mortgage
sisters these deep-pocket
government-sponsored enterprises they
had to back in the federal government on
the top of that there was a delusion
that Alan Greenspan head of the Fed
would remaining who remained in office
through January 2006 would come to the
rescue if anything went wrong the bank
he loved to hate the guy in the starched
collar at the branch bank on Main Street
he would turn you down for a mortgage
because your income wasn't high enough
got elbowed aside by banksters like
Angelo Mozilo of the mortgage issuer
country right who would give anybody a
mortgage because the government was
there to assume the risk
many of these bankers did indeed get
bailed out by the government as did
Freddie and Fannie I remained the banker
you loved to hate and I knew at the time
that Fannie and Freddie were going bust
and the Greenspan had created a
financial house of cards I've heard mark
claimed the private sector lost BAM more
mortgages were much higher than losses
incurred by the government I've seen a
moody study published that tries to
butter is this claim in fact a possible
look at the data shows the opposite that
a government accounting from even
greater losses but it's true that
private sector losses were quite
substantial when you consider it's much
smaller commitment one reason is that
Freddie and Fannie had the power as pay
setting institutions backed by the
government to cherry-pick the best the
worst mortgages the best of the worst
mortgages of leaving the private sector
with the more risky mortgages the
private sector also entered the market
much later at much higher prices with
mortgages whose average dollar value was
higher so when the crash in prices came
the lower down payment mortgages
say hell were underwater much sooner and
therefore lost much more I've heard mark
make the point that other countries
experience house price bubbles that's
true since they too have central banks
central banks that have to follow the
lead of the Fed because the US has the
world's reserve currency but the key
difference was that when the bus came
the US had a much larger proportion of
toxic mortgages than any other country
I've heard their excuse mark repeated
repeat the excuse given by a Greenspan
and successor of Ben Bernanke the
housing market was distorted by savings
but but a brought from abroad but much
of what they call a savings glut was
monetary expansion globally by central
banks that was only possible because the
Federal Reserve's action the so called
Savings Club distorted our housing
market mainly because the huge
distortion imposed by Freddie and Fannie
and the Fed itself it's hard to
underneath it's hard to overestimate the
negative impact on lending by private
lenders through the regulatory attack on
banks forcing banks to do lending that
they weren't designed to do and and that
really got the ball rolling
that led eventually to the financial
crisis thank you very much
well you still kept your full 15 minutes
mark even though John finished early
well thank you Jean thank you so hope
for him for the opportunity to be here a
great place great venue very intimate
she and I go way back I think must be 25
or 30 years so thank you for the
invitation and it's great to be on the
stage with John Ellison a great guy
fantastic bank BB&T is certainly one of
the best we I've worked with being BB&T
over the years and still do and it's
testimonial to your your leadership so
you've done a fantastic job I just want
to say that I'm not just an egghead
economist I am the chief economist of
Moody's Analytics but I think it's
apropos given the subject matter just to
give you a little bit of of context
about me I started my own company an
economic consulting firm with my brother
and my best friend and we sold it to the
Moody's corporation now almost 15 years
ago it's hard to believe when when we
sold it we were a good size small
company about a little over a hundred
employees with offices in different
parts of the world so I've been a part
of a start-up I've been part of a small
business and now I'm part of a large
multinational corporation I'm also on
the board of directors of mortgage MGIC
a mortgage and sure one of the largest
in the country and I'm the lead director
of reinvestment fund which is a CDFI if
you don't know what that is it's a non
profit investment community development
financial institution we invest in
underserved communities all across the
country including in this region of the
country so the point is I am a
card-carrying member of the private
markets I know it well I do think one
more important point I am part of the
Moody's Corp but I'm not part of the
rating agency so I'm totally separate
from the rating agency and
in a separate independent organization
okay let me begin by saying that there
are many causes for the financial crisis
plenty of blame to go around except me
it's not my fault I had nothing to do
with it although president Trump did try
to pin it on me back in the 2016
campaign a press release he didn't like
what I was saying about his proposed
economic policies and apparently I was
the one who started the crisis but I had
nothing to do I was okay with that when
it turned out that he also went after
warren buffett in the same press release
I'm okay to be in the same press release
with Warren Buffett you know anything
he's doing I'm good with so wait I had
nothing to do with it
I think the principal reason for the
crisis however was a colossal collapse
in the private markets in the financial
system and more specifically in the
complete failure in the mortgage
securitization process the private
mortgage securitization process the
private-label securities that john had
in one of his charts pretty
straightforward in the securitization
process lenders originated mortgage
lenders originate loans those loans are
then sold to investment banks trusts
investment banks package those loans and
take the principal interest generated by
those loans to back security some
mortgage securities that they the
investment banks then sell to global
investors across the club of course the
rating agencies rate those securities
and the global investors use those
ratings as an input into their decision
around whether to invest in those
securities that's the mortgage
securitization process it's still
functioning today it's a shadow of what
it was but you know back in the day
prior to the crisis it was you
was rip-roarin and the mortgage
securitization process and again I'm
speaking to you as a person in the
middle of the process watching it was
broken the machine was completely out of
sync
from the beginning to the end lenders
unscrupulous lenders originated loans
that they knew would be unaffordable
that ultimately borrowers who took on
those mortgages would not be able to pay
them in many cases they weren't the BB
and T's of the world not the regulated
banking system they they weren't the
real problem it was the non banks and
the so-called shadow system the country
wives of the world the Angelo Mozilo zuv
the world the new centuries of the world
that's where we got ninja loans no
income no job no asset of course
borrowers weren't completely innocent in
all this
we had many home buyers that were
investors in fact at the peak of the
investment flipping in the housing
market back in 2005 2006 nearly 20% of
all homes that were sold were to
investors and of course these investors
pass themselves off as homeowners
because if they were homeowners they'd
get better terms on the mortgage loan a
lower interest rate and they didn't have
to put as much down into the mortgage so
they lied about it
and so there was plenty of fraud going
on in the mortgage market at this time
so in fact I remember one just very
incredible statistic in Ocean City New
Jersey that's a that's actually a
metropolitan area there's a lower for
near metropolitan errs across the
country Ocean City in New Jersey in 2005
and this is HMDA data Home Mortgage
Disclosure Act data seventy percent of
all the loans originated in that year
were to investors to investors so
lenders were deeply involved if the
investment banks they were making a they
were minting money and in buying those
loans securitizing them and selling them
off and the entire business model was
revolved around volume we need they need
to generate high levels of activity high
levels of
and so they took anyone they got they
securitized it sold off to global
investors and they went on to the next
deal rating agencies were involved
believe it or not back in the day prior
to the crisis the rating agencies policy
was and this was a stated policy that
was written for everyone to see it was
public information that the rating
agency would not underwrite the loans
themselves they took the information
that the investment bank gave them about
the mortgage loans and used that in
their decision around what rating to
provide on the Securities obviously that
was an egregious error in the sense that
you know these loans it was quite
obvious many of them were far progeny
poorly underwritten but no wonder
writing was doing but again that was
kind of the way the rating agency that
was the way the rating agency rating
agencies operated with regard to other
debt and they just applied that same
business model to them to the mortgage
loans and then there's the global
investors the global investors they were
inundated with capital we did have a
global savings collide largely most
fundamentally because it was a period
after which China had entered into the
World Trade Organization and came on the
global scene very rapidly they started
to run a very large current trade
surplus and a current account surplus
they were getting a lot of dollars in
trade I mean they came into the WTO in
2001 by the mid-2000s they were rolling
in cash and that money those were
dollars that had to come back into the
United States they went to investment
managers investment managers were
flooded with the cash they didn't know
what to do with it they did stop doing
due diligence they solely relied on the
ratings and they plunked down good
capital on these bad loans and it goes
beyond that
I mean exacerbating all of this were
different features of the system that
ultimately failed there were investment
vehicles out there that so-called
structured investment vehicles sibs you
may remember the Citibank sieve that
blew up in 2007 2008 that borrowed money
short-term money at a low interest rate
that money and use that to finance
purchases of
subprime mortgage securities and other
debt mortgage mortgage bonds and of
course when you borrow short and you're
funding a purchase of an asset that's
the long duration you set yourself up
for a problem if short-term interest
rates rise and funding gets cut off
which is exactly what happened the
derivative market took off unregulated
that was key to allowing investors and
speculators to double down triple down
on their bets in the mortgage market and
of course most fundamentally the entire
financial system including the banking
system maybe not be a B and T but most
banks including Fannie Mae and Freddie
Mac which is their the reason for their
failure was that they were
undercapitalized they hold very little
capital cushion cash in the cash in a
sense in the bank that was sitting there
in case to pay for losses that they
would ultimately suffer and they didn't
have enough capital to withstand the
losses that came so the system really
was totally broken during this period
and you can you can see this in my first
I have a couple of three slides forward
yeah this is this shows you how
significant the growth was you know
there's an old a banking adage it goes
maybe John knows us the bank energy goes
if it's growing like a weed it's
probably a weed and that describes the
private mortgage market and you can see
that here this shows the share of
mortgage debt outstanding residential
mortgage debt outstanding that's
accounted for by the private-label
securities market this is the
securitization market that I've been
talking about the private market and
contrasting that with a share of
mortgage debt that's accounted for by
Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac and this
accounts for every mortgage asset
whether it's a loan or security on the
balance sheet you can see that the
private-label securities market took off
there's the weed between mid 2003 and
mid 2007 and share mortgage debt
outstanding rose by over 10 percentage
points by the way this is not
origination this is mortgage debt
outstanding for those who follow this
carefully so that gives you a sense of
in terms of regeneration volume the
share going to the private-label
securities market was sustainably more
than this and you can see at the same
time no surprise the share of mortgage
debt accounted for can't afford by
Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac fell by 10
percentage points so it's the
private-label securities market they
came on very rapidly grew very quickly
the weed and it overtook the the
agencies Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac and
you know it clearly led to the egregious
problems that we had during this period
and of course the losses reflect that
this shows who suffered the most who
suffered the losses during the financial
crisis the lending that was done through
the financial crisis this is just adding
up in dollar terms the defaults the blue
bar represents the losses on mortgage
loans originated in the bubble in 2003
through 2006 early 2007 by the private
market and the Green Line represents the
losses on
backed by the government including
Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac I mean
obviously they weren't part of the
government prior crisis but they were
implicitly backed and I included them
and it also includes FHA VA through the
entire crisis total losses on all
mortgage loans was just over a trillion
dollars so if you look at all the losses
and all the mortgage loans originated
during this bubble period it was about a
trillion dollars for context there's ten
trillion dollars of mortgage debt
outstanding so the lost rate on mortgage
debt outstanding was ten percent ten
percent of the value of all mortgage
debt defaulted if you add up the blue
bars over time that comes up to five
hundred and fifty billion dollars so
that's over half of all the losses that
were incurred during as a result of
crisis on those loans originated during
that period we're in the private market
over half the accounted for 10 20
percent of the market they account for
over half the losses and of course the
product the government sector much
smaller share than their debt
outstanding no let me in this way
I'm not saying and I'm not arguing the
government didn't play a role in all of
us it did but it's not what John thinks
it is it's not the head it's not
government's heavy hand and overbearing
relationship to the markets that caused
the crisis it's the lack of oversight on
the markets that caused the crisis where
were the regulator's during this period
they were gone they were gone they were
nowhere to be found
the first guidance that regulators the
Federal Reserve the OCC the FDIC issued
with regard to subprime lending was in
July of 2006 the bubble was already
bursting by that point in time they
there was no derivative there was no
regulation of the derivatives AIG lorded
up on three trillion dollars of notional
value of derivatives there was no
regulation or oversight of the
structured investment vehicles in fact
when the city's sieve blew up it was it
was a surprise to everyone including the
regulators the lenders that blew up the
the guys who took out the system they
weren't the regulated banks they were
the non regulated banks it was a
countrywide of the world that took out
Bank of America
was the new centuries of the world that
took out the financial system so it's
not the government's heavy hand it's in
fact just the opposite the government
was nowhere to be found
and it was the government that at the
end of the day saved the day and you can
see that here this shows a measure of
stress in the financial system it's the
so-called Ted spread it's the difference
between the rate on LIBOR that's the
interest rate that banks charge each
other for buying and lending to each
other relative to the Treasury yield
which is a risk-free rate so the if
that's if that difference increases that
stress in the marketplace the bankers
are saying to the to the other bankers I
don't believe that you're going to be
able to pay me back so you've got to pay
me a higher interest rate and you can
see that the the earthquake started back
in 2007 with Bear Stearns it became
earth-shattering you know in 2008 on the
other side of Lehman Brothers in Fannie
Mae and Freddie Mac and it was only with
government intervention ultimately the
tarp which was the bailout fund and
interestingly enough factoid the day
this spread peak and in my mind the day
the financial crisis began to come to an
end was the day that the FDIC guaranteed
bank that saying it's money good if you
invest in Bank dead and that marked the
end of the crisis in distress so I'm a
card-carrying member of the market
system and I'm here to tell you it was
the market system that failed it was not
the government thank you
so so on rebuttal from John Allison and
can we you got a phone call yeah okay
yeah yeah yeah maybe yeah Jane Menten
can help you there
timekeepers yeah Oh God
okay start the chiming sorry for that
boys closely tracked articles and court
talks he's already published he's simply
decided to advance to the housing bubble
only began in late 2003 any academic
would say no it started a long time when
the private sector is hard to become
more involved in the mortgage market but
I walk into the movie the final really
misses all the decisive events that
occurred until late 2003 in the January
2019 working paper called mortgage risk
since 1990 analysts with the Fed raised
you see this is report say we show the
mortgage risks had already risen in the
nineties planning and see for the mantle
crisis since Mark's own data revealed
the government dominated the mortgage
market the 90s and early 2000s just
final statement to be sufficient
evidence
the real story began before the 2004
period to here are two other snapshots
of the time of the housing bubble this
one traces house prices to rents which
hit a new high in December 2000 and in a
paper published title house prices
bubbles in March of 2003 an economist
with the Federal Reserve in San
Francisco reported with concern that the
ratio between house prices and rents
resembling a price bubble remember its
prices that are bubbles in this chart
number 2 here again show how private
institutions were lured in the plug into
the by the double-digit increase in
house prices early as August 1919 in New
England Martine to think it's critical
to show figures comparing mortgage
losses by government versus those by the
private sector I'm not sure that's true
but anyway here's Martin has not already
published
these same figures in the Moose report
by itemizing mortgage losses that mark
myths that should help to gain
perspective on the long reach of
government mark estimated losses a 275
billion are based solely on those
directly incurred by FHA Fannie and
Freddie this table as itemized losses
directly in curbed by government or
losses for which government is directly
responsible
notice that we end up with a full tally
of 516 billion our first item of 41
billion comes right from Fannie and
Fannie's financial statements is the
amount that private insurance companies
paid them on losing mortgages so while
the forty 1 billion wasn't technically a
loss of the enterprise's it was a loss
imposed in the private sector by
government
similarly fitting Fannie were able to
get private sector issues to buy back
many of their losing mortgages with
threats the results of our second item a
managed to impose on the private sector
28 billion the 85 billion my atom
represents losses that resulted from
fannie and freddie purchases of more
than 700 billion dollars worth of
subprime mortgage-backed securities and
a hundred fifty being them high-risk
securities called all day the 40 billion
Iowa item represents losses on huge
private sector deals that only got
implemented in response to government
unfortunately the Community Reinvestment
Act the final display shows that losses
properly attributed to government may be
will higher than the losses attribute of
the private sector we start with this
figures publishing marks moody study and
make plausible adjustments begin with we
reduced Moody's estimate of private
losses by one hundred and thirty nine
billion dollars based on the National
Bureau crook Bureau of Economic Research
working paper published last April which
reports very different figures from
Moody's University of Chicago economist
Paul Harold pull off their paper writes
in an email that he contacted mark twice
asking for his sources and mark wouldn't
provide them finally we reduced Moody's
number by 220 billion reflect all the
losses mark attributed private said
before which governments actually
responsible the result is government
accounts for more than half and losses I
would also say absolute certainty from
personal experience that a substantial
percentage of private losses were driven
by significant regulatory pressure on
private institutions there wasn't a
light hand
God was the hand of government pounding
on your head trying to make you make
subprime mortgages and we have the
consequences of that thank you
five minutes from our contact here I'll
give you my card I get contacted by lots
of people I maybe I don't know I send
him my way I'll be happy to set him
straight
so John my read of your argument is
twofold one is that the Federal Reserve
was overly stimulatory with monetary
policy and the lead-up to the bubble and
that exacerbated housing demand and
therefore house price growth and
ultimately helped create the bubble in
second that Fannie and Freddie because
of their very aggressive affordable
lending lending to underserved groups
helped to stimulate a more broader
erosion in underwriting standards across
the system and I'd say on on both I
think there bit players in the story
with regard to the Federal Reserve they
did straight-up monetary policy they if
you look at the interest you mean if you
go back I can remember the sticks pretty
well that the federal funds rate hit a
bottom that's the key interest rate the
Fed control said the bottom of 1% in the
wake of the bursting of the stock market
bubble in 2004 and then rose to five and
a quarter percent at the peak just prior
to the crash if you kind of look back at
that period and you look at the things
that the Fed looks at and trying to set
monetary policy the so-called feds react
function straight-up monetary policy
unemployment inflation financial market
conditions
you know broader global economic
conditions the the funds rate was very
very close to you know what those
traditional approaches to monetary
policy would be yeah could you argue
they could have done a better job in
hindsight obviously you know that
everyone screwed up but it's hard to put
place the you know the blame significant
blame on them they were just they
followed the script and historically the
script has worked pretty well since 1913
when the Federal Reserve was put on the
planet clearly our financial system and
economy have performed much better than
than prior to that period with regard to
Fannie and Freddie I don't get that one
at all and I know there are some
proponents of the idea that you know
Fannie and Freddie's lending to
underserved communities is the cause a
major cause of what happened I don't
think there's any evidence of that
in fact the academic literature is very
clear there's been a dozen different
studies done on this issue controlled
experiments st. Louis I would I would
direct you to a couple of very good
studies that done by the st. Louis Fed
and the Fed Board of Governors and they
come to the conclusion that the
affordable housing goals had nothing to
do with what happened and you know I I
am in faith I think Fannie Mae and
Freddie Mac because of their mission
should be geared towards providing
affordable credit to lower in
middle-income households that's what
they were put on the planet to do and
and that's their mission I don't think
the affordable housing goals are a
particularly good way of getting them to
achieve their mission but it's not
because they were the cause of the
crisis or they lead to poorer
underwriting it's because they're
totally ineffective there's very little
evidence in fact no evidence that those
goals
there's affordable housing goals have
had anything to do with Fannie and
Freddie's underwriting so you know
with your arguments you know I wouldn't
completely dismiss them but if I had a
list of ten different things ten
different causes of the crisis by the
way there are so many reasons for this
crisis that one could write a book and I
did I did yeah it's worth the dollar
ninety-nine on eBay but I would suggest
you go read it because it kind of lays
out you know who's to blame the Fed is a
chapter in the book but it is definitely
a bit player in all of this thank you
both for spirited exchange we now move
to the QA part of the evening and would
you guys will you be willing to do a
little grunt work and move your chairs
and I think that our sound guy wants to
move the mics to make sure that our
klutzy guys do not wreck the mics and
we're going to do that and we are going
to start with I guess moderators
prerogative to to sort of pick up on a
strand for each of you first John
Allison do you acknowledge what's your
reaction to Mark's point that there was
a failure of regulation and in India
that there was a major sin of omission
on the part of government with visa V
the behavior of the private sector well
it was a fait it was a failure of
regulation but it was the inverse of
what Marx says there was huge pressure
on financial institutions to make
low-income housing lives and it's
important to understand the context
because it really started with Bill
Clinton and it wasn't about low income
it was about minority lending
specifically the african-american
community so it was a huge pressure on
financial institutions and you really
couldn't argue just about low income
lending because it Mike like BB&T we
were in low-income areas but you had to
prove that you were being super careful
and and a lot of banks made a lot of
regular loans that didn't classify this
as subprime loans too low not low income
bars with bars with lousy credit
histories you have to understand
the lending business to understand that
income that to debt service is one
factor but a bigger factor is just what
people gonna pay you and and that
encouraged this bubble and also became
almost a moral campaign on the
regulator's part so it was it was yes it
was a lot of regulatory pressure but it
was in the wrong direction from a credit
quality and by the way a lot of
regulators knew that you could hear them
they would tell you that I'm not coming
on that and that's good question and
comment on John's answer what do you
want to pass about up to you not never
pass okay let me tell you a story so it
was late 2005 I was asked to go brief
the FOMC this is the Federal Open Market
Committee the folks at the Federal
Reserve Greenspan was this is just
towards the end of his tenure at the Fed
and they asked me to come speak about
the developing issues with regard to the
mortgage industry this was late 2005 so
you know we were still a long way from
the crisis and but it was you know you
could feel things getting very frothy a
lot of investors flippers house price
growth that now has gotten into the
double digits and I had some insight
into it because I was able to tap into
the rating agencies data with regard to
because really it's hard to hard to
believe this but back at the time we
didn't even know there wasn't even a
clear definition of subprime mortgage we
just kind of throw that term around but
in 2005 there no one really knew what
that meant so but we had data from the
from the private-label securities and so
I could look at that and gain some
insight into what was going on so I go
into the meeting at the Fed in DC and I
get my presentation it might have been I
don't know half hour 45 minutes and they
listened and at the end of that there
was not a single question not one
question
not one and I and I was pretty dark I
was saying this is a problem this is a
weed if it can
we're gonna have a real problem I was
writing extensively about it at the time
and I wrote a piece called where are the
regulator's
and I heard I had one question when I
left that meeting
you know Greenspan was right there and
he's looking at me not a question I left
that meeting I go oh my gosh I have this
wrong I must have this wrong they are
saying what about this they don't think
there's an issue there's not a problem
now here's the thing Greenspan had a
stated policy of I'm not gonna worry
about bubbles this is not my problem
you know Greenspan had you know he did
monetary policy in the Fed is the key
regulatory body in the system right so
he had a state of policy of saying I'm
not going to I don't know if there's a
bubble or not I'll clean up the mess
when it blows and that's the policy he
was pursuing there was not a regulator
in sight and the chief regulator was
sitting right there and saying it's not
my problem okay and the question for
mark did I believe that that Robert
Shiller called
called up the price what some call the
price bubble of price boom but he
specifically stated recently in fact
that and I believe that John Cornyn that
that the price boom the biggest price
boom started in early 97 and went
through 2006 and that it was more than
half done
more than halfway through as a bubble of
boom by 2003 would you now now is that
based on prices that that did indeed
occur and that there was indeed a major
boom bubble that that that occurred from
97 through 2003 to 2006 do you know it's
that in terms of John's argument no I
think a bubble a housing bubble any
bubble in it anymore what we call the
boom let's go to boom no let's call it a
bubble well yeah okay it's a bubble it's
a bubble Wynn and Michael are buying
homes or any asset a stock commercial
property whatever it is based simply on
the fact that they think that property
is going to be worth a lot more soon in
the future and I can sell okay so
tonight can I change my question
call it a boob just answer can I just
simply say he called it a boom so let's
call it a boom he said there was a price
boom from today 97 that went through
2006 do you now let's chill this point
that there was a price boom as he put it
not a probably put he called it a boom
so was it a boom that's okay let me
answer the question this way okay the
between up and through 2003 the increase
in housing values was very consistent
with underlying fundamentals that drive
housing demand and house price growth
the there was strong house price growth
but you know if you go look at the data
look at any house price index you want
to look at Case Shiller his index look
at the FHFA at the time of sale price
Series price growth was 5 4 5 6 % per
annum this is through mid 2003 and
household income growth in that period
on average was 4 5 6 % rent growth was 4
5 6 % construction costs were 4 5 6 %
these are the fundamentals that drive
underlying housing values now there was
a period when it got juiced up after the
equity market fell because people pulled
money out of the equity market this was
you know 2001 was the crash in the
equity market and people said well what
did I put my money and they started
putting it into the into the housing
market the real switch went on in
between mid 2003 in early 2007 it was in
that period that house price growth went
from 4 or 5 6 % pick your index I know
this data because I model it this is
what I do for a living
i model it it went up into the double
digits per annum it increased between
2000 in 2003 in mid 2007 and that was a
bubble that was a bubble because house
price growth was disconnected from the
growth in the underlying fundamentals
and that was speculation and so it was
that period when this metastasized and
became a problem for the financial
system and ultimately the economy so no
I don't I don't that all agree with the
idea that there was a bubble
prior to sorry a boom boom there was a
but I'm not okay
whatever it was a bubble post-2000 you
insisted on the word bubble so that's
why I said Shiller used the word boom he
said it was the one number one boom that
started in 97 and went to 2006 boom is
different than the bubble you can have a
boom if it's supported by underlying
good fundamentals right comment from
John I think shell arm in a bubble and
anybody that was in the lending business
was observed observing the obvious fact
this goes back to the early nineteen to
late 1990s the price relative to
people's income there for debt service
when you finance a house relative to
income was headed up very rapidly and
reach in the late 1990s equivalence to
the early 1990s when we had a housing
bus and the early nineteen eighties me
house had a housing bus and and the
price to rinse was going nuts or in
there were 99 we thought we were gonna
have a housing correction in the early
2000 when the stock markets for
correcting this is when Greenspan
stepped on the gas that was in this
slide and started pumping out money like
crazy but book by loaner interest rate
but more than that right price Pisces
should have been falling when you have a
huge increase in productivity because
the entry of the Chinese and the Indians
in the world market prices would
normally fall if you think about if
productivity is rising very rapidly if
you had a stable money supply prices
would be falling if you don't let prices
fall it's worse than normal inflation
because people don't realize inflation
is happening and they become overly
optimistic and that is that Spurs a
massive increase in consumption and
housing is consumption not investment so
we had a huge miss allocation of capital
away from capital investment we weren't
put anything in capital he was running
you know the savings but is of his faith
because US savings rates that were
falling and and and and and we were over
investing in consumption and housing and
it would have corrected in the early
1990s we had a little worth correction
then and then we wouldn't have had to
run up I agree with Mark at the end of
the bubble a lot of people who jumped on
just like they do in the stock market
but the momentum was already there that
that's what carries that kind of stuff
the bubble had already started and it
got blown up by a bunch of fools that
should have gone broke but but they were
secondary players I'm good thanks and
now also a moderator obligation to ask
you before the audience ask questions do
you want to ask your other a question
now or do you want to wait 40s but you
always have the product of you guys
other questions you want to wave on that
or do ask each other a question ok no
questions for the audience please phrase
your question as a question as best you
can
first question don't identify yourself
as a person your credentials do identify
just as so forum person a very well was
a pretty weird my name is Paul Muller I
teach economics downtown I have students
here I saw him both of your books we
don't we don't care all right here's my
question for mark mark so it seems that
underwriting standards are really
important in this story and the
declining underwriting standards so my
question is with countrywide and indymac
and these other sorts of unregulated
lenders and sort of the subprime area
who was buying their loans in in 1999
2000 2001 2002 before the private market
and the investment banks jumped on that
so who woods buying them and could you
comment on alt a loans and sort of the
difference between traditional prime
loans and alt a loans which are not to
poor people and yet are not the
traditional prime loans with 20% down
and other sorts of things thank you
well I think back in the late 90s early
2004 things really got going these
companies were a shadow of the market
they were very small I mean countrywide
was the biggest and it was still you
know pretty small player at the time it
really didn't these companies really
didn't become significant players in the
mortgage market until that period you
know when you saw the private level
securities market really take off you
know into that between 2003 and early
2007 so you know i don't i don't think
they it was they were inconsequential in
the grand scheme korean scheme of things
so what was your second question when I
say subprime generally in the context of
this kind of a group I'm also
considering all day
option arms Nega em arms I'm really
thrown in the hole any mortgage loan
that you basically can't make today
right because one of the regulatory
changes in dodd-frank was the so-called
qualified Mortgage rule but this is this
is disbeliever this or not this this
rule is if you're a mortgage lender you
can't make a loan to a borrower who
can't afford to pay it that's the rule
right that rule was not in place before
dodd-frank and these are the loans that
are no longer in existence because
borrowers can't afford to pay them right
so I include all of that in when I say
when I study subprime you know for this
kind of an audience not for you know he
can't professor but you know for this
kind of audience although maybe you're
only compras I not me thanks mark
John do you want to comment no okay next
question hi do either of you view what
is going on currently with student
student loans to be anything similar to
what happened with the the housing
bubble so if and if you do think it is a
similar boom or bubble is there anything
we can take from what happened back in
2008 that we can use to avert a similar
catastrophe if that bubble if it is a
bubble does burst let me give it to John
fresh because you winters in question I
think there is a key similarity and that
is that if you increase the amount of
leverage to purchase something
I mean you allow people to borrow money
in lenders extend credit to buy
something and it's against a something
that has a relatively fixed supply it's
hard to increase the supply what happens
is the price goes up right you're just
increasing demand and that's to some
degree what happened in the mortgage
market right you through all this
borrowing on to the housing market and
you had the supply was increasing but
not enough and so that helped to drive
up prices that's the same principle in
the loan student loan market we are
subsidizing the
and we're giving subsidy to increase the
demand for educational services and
that's a very fixed supply right so all
you're doing is jacking up tuition so at
the end of the day you're not really
helping anybody the poor kids are just
loaded up with debt and you're on the
you know a treadmill so the implication
for me I mean my takeaway from that and
I'm talking as an economist without the
strictures of policy and having to make
legislation that works just as an
economist I would say I would take that
subsidy that we're putting into student
loan debt instead of making the interest
rate low and making it more available I
take that subsidy that money that
taxpayer money and I use that to
increase the supply of educational
services right community colleges
technical schools eLearning increase the
supply so if you increase the supply you
bring down the cost these kids don't
have that debt and they have access to
better educational services that's easy
to say and you know it's it's very
difficult to get there from here but if
I were king for the day that's the path
I would go down I agree with Mark's
analysis of what student debt has done
it's just driven at the price
universities I think it is like the
housing bond bubble in this sense and it
is causing a massive misallocation of
resources because what's happening and
I'm very involved in the educational
process a lot of people are going to
universities spending a lot of money not
graduating or graduating with degrees
where their productivity hadn't been
increased so you've got a Mis allocation
of the most valuable resource of all for
human mind there's a lot of students at
universities today that ought to be in
some kind of I don't want us call
technical training demeaning they ought
to be learning how to do other things
and what liberal arts universities tend
to teach them to do and I think so
there's a double whammy it's the
economics Marc talked about but it's
also you've seen something like 25
percent of the kids that graduate with
college degrees are getting
jobs they don't need college degrees for
I'd say that make one another quick
point so one big difference is that
there's 1.3 trillion in student loan
debt outstanding 1.15 trillion is
government backed right so it's a
taxpayer problem in the mortgage market
just go back to my slide the vast vast
majority of the debt was private market
debt and when that blew up that became a
financial system problem and that's why
that that period in 2008-2009 was the
financial crisis it took out the
financial system the student loan
problem won't take out the financial
system it's our problem as taxpayers we
did have a debate at the so forum about
college a few months ago I refer you to
that on a website the video and the
audio are both available next question
mark this one's for you so private-label
securities at the epicenter of the
crisis investors bought them investors
are bad market failure boom you're done
who bought them people who bought them
for the rating but they're just bad
investors they read consumer reports
bought the wrong car it was a lemon why
did they buy them if they had a triple-a
on them is it because the bank capital
rules said they could be
undercapitalized and whole point six
percent of capital to hold them so if a
nationally recognized statistical rating
organization went to a bank that's
regulated by the government that said
you could hold point six percent of
capital if you bought a triple-a
security and then clever people on Wall
Street maybe not dissimilar from me went
out and figured out a way to have some
pride borrowers speculate on houses that
were going up ten percent a year to have
Moody's and S&P issue triple-a
securities to banks a couple point six
percent of capital how is that not a
government induced distortion of markets
how do you not support the resolution
you would yeah no you are not in charge
of the ratings mark I say that on your
behalf so but go ahead
no no it's I'm sympathetic what you're
saying it goes to the point I made
earlier about lack of regulation that
the system was undercapitalized and it
was undercapitalized across the system
you mentioned one aspect of it
Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac hold held 40
basis points of capital
you know back prior to the crisis so if
there was a government failure it was a
government failure of regulation so I'm
I'm I don't disagree with that I I think
that did contribute now that wasn't the
cause of the crisis that was an
exacerbation force that made the crisis
as severe as it was Fannie Mae and
Freddie Mac didn't cause the crisis but
when the losses started to mount because
of what happened in the private markets
and house prices started to decline as a
result that wiped out their very thin
capital they failed and it exacerbated
the financial the finished price it
wasn't the cause it was a it was a a
factor that contributed to the severity
of the downturn if I could start a new
century members please I'm sorry we only
a question we can talk offline I'm very
happy to yeah of course talk offline and
you are sticking around for the booze
standard Poor's Moody's and Fitch had a
government created oligopoly where
basically they could they were the only
rating agencies that you could use for
evaluating bonds and pension funds so
they owned the bond rating business they
miss rated lots of instruments
dramatically and that was government
regulation that gave him the oligopoly
by the way I won right old you my
company BB&T went through the financial
crisis without a single court he lost
one reasons we wouldn't use to enforce
Moody's and Fitch Ratings
because I've been to the economic
correct early eighties I've been to the
economic surely 90s I looked at these
things and said any fool knows these are
high risk instruments they've reacted
I'm triple triple-a I mean remember this
too though terms of regulators there was
a regulation you had to keep half as
much capital and a subprime mortgage as
you did to a loan to Exxon and you want
to create an incentive for people to do
subprime mortgages encourage banks to
put half the capital and subprime
mortgage and if you don't do that by the
way that puts a lot of pressure on you
because you can't perform this high in
the short term you know the other guy's
going broke but you gotta stay in
business
or terms they put a lot of pressure on
healthy institutions to do stupid stuff
and some of them did some of them dude
next question
well to continue on the theme is Mark
Zandi pointed out one of the
contributing factors was the undue
reliance on these ratings in retrospect
they turned out to be worth not much
more than a peewee soccer trophy has
anything been done by the rating
agencies to improve their rate or make
them actually worth something anymore
[Laughter]
and I'm sympathetic of the criticisms of
the rating agencies they mean like many
of players in this system they screwed
up I mean there's no doubt about that
yes there has been some changes remember
in my opening remarks I talked about the
rating agency stated policy of not
underwriting the underlying mortgages
that had went into the securities that
has changed so now they're they use
randomized sampling to go and take a
look at the mortgages and they
underwrite they can't underwrite every
mortgage because there's millions of
mortgages but that that statistically is
you know an adequate way of approaching
it the the kind of internal controls
you know another problem the rating
agencies had back in pre-crisis was a
problem with something called ratings
shopping that would be the investment
banks would go to each of the to the
rating agencies and play one off the
other and say if you give me basically
was you know obviously not this blatant
but this was kind of the way things were
being done they would say you know if I
get a better rating you'll get this the
deal and of course the fate that now is
there's no given all the changes in
regular regulation and regulatory
oversight rating shopping is a very very
very unlikely thing to happen going for
it possible but we now we have very
strong regulatory controls and oversight
over that process to make that much less
likely oh I'm sorry I don't know can I
just say this is a good point
this is a really good point so you're
right you know the inheritor feels like
there's an inherent conflict right when
you say the investors pay the for the
rating so if someone's paying for the
rating then the agency is going to give
a rating that the investors want and I
you know I think that's clearly a
problem an issue but the thing is no
one's come up with a better mousetrap
because you know it means you don't I
mean when I say I should have said the
rating agency is paid by the issuer not
by the investor right it's the issue or
that pays for it not the investor
there's a you know ideas that maybe the
investor should pay for it that's a
pretty bad idea would you really want
you know a hedge fund to be paying for
the ratings
probably not there's been ideas floated
around of random I randomly selecting
rating agencies to do it so that you
can't have this problem
there's all kinds of issues with that in
terms of quality of the ratings and the
analysis this time so at the end of the
day the system has now fallen back on
let's keep the same approach the same
model but let's improve the regulatory
controls an oversight better and more
stringent regulation that wasn't there
you know pre-crisis is that mean that
we're not gonna have a problem in the
future you know I don't know but it's
less likely we're going to problem in
the future and we should fundamentally
ask you know we the rating agencies are
an easy whipping-boy but they're there
for a reason and I won't go that's a
whole other discussion maybe another
debate but it's actually quite
interesting to ask yourself why do we
have rating agencies because they play a
very important role in the system coming
by John I think Morris why they've taken
a lot of steps but I would say this now
I'm retired from BB&T but the day I
retired we were still underwriting the
bonds ourselves we didn't trust the
rating agencies and our experiences
sometimes their ratings were pretty good
and sometimes they
so I think anybody that's really a
sophisticated buyer you can you can
write you can write these things
yourself within a within a range just by
reading the instruments in there so did
I say that I'm not in the reading agency
next question some of this has already
been answered as I've been standing in
the line but I wanted to ask John can
you give us some specific examples of
the pressure that was put on BB&T to
make loans and or to to join into the
bubble as it was as it was going up and
and the second part what did you do to
resist it how were you able to resist it
at particularly being in the middle of a
a low income and heavily minority
community like you were yeah well the
pressure came from two sides it came
from the banking regulators themselves
the FDIC and the Federal Reserve who
were very regulatory active the idea
that that we were deregulation is absurd
read the record regulations went off the
chart a lot of it was about compliance
and not about lending but on the lending
side there was huge pressure to get you
to make affordable housing low income
minority loans about what were the years
John to just tell the years go in you
account what years was this it started
back with Bill Clinton in the in the mid
1990s Clinton was elected by a strong
african-american community and he wanted
to pay him back he believed there was
discrimination in the banking business I
don't believe there ever was we
certainly weren't discriminating but
they put intense pressure on this
starting in the late 1990s and then
Freddie and Fannie when they
particularly when they had their
accounting problems they had to keep
their government guarantees as they were
left they had there were leverage at one
point a thousand to one I mean they were
broke before they were broke but they
got these survived with government
guarantees then they cost called us we
were originating for Freddie and Fannie
which we would have done cept they have
a government guarantee and they have a
lower cost of capital which made it
impossible for us to port for
mortgages they had driven down the
standards radically to meet this
affordable housing go which they bragged
about by the way I mean they were proud
of it but they were doing and they were
told us they were gonna cut us off from
our prime business unless we did more
subprime business so we danced around
that there was also investor pressure to
have the high performance you could get
in the short term from doing this
terrible stuff out of our big we've
actually run out of time for the
questions mark do you want to make a
comment about what John just said about
his own Lord what do you want okay all
right thanks thanks unfortunately no
more time for questions plenty of time
to talk to the debaters after the debate
we're now going to go to the summary
portion of the evening John Allison
you're up with your summary my summaries
pretty basic it is true that a number of
private financial institutions played an
important role and created the financial
crisis however the primary culprits were
the Federal Reserve and government
housing policies specifically Freddie
Mac and Fannie Mae but also the FHA VA
and regulatory pressure that you could
have half as much capital in a in a
subprime mortgage as you could do a loan
to Exxon along with the lots of other
regulatory pressure it is not true the
banking industry was deregulated you can
look at the record there was a huge
increase in regulations during this
period of time and and certainly there
was plenty of greed on Wall Street if
I've been in the banking business 47
years and there's always plenty of greed
on Wall Street it's all of its good some
of its bad there was no new amount of
greed going on on Wall Street it is hard
unless you were down and down in the in
the trenches when people get all these
kind of numbers and pull of stuff out
you can't measure it the way it's being
measured because a lot of private losses
weren't technically in CRA loans they
weren't technically in private
mortgage-backed securities they were in
loans that financial institutions were
making it by the way we keep saying the
countrywide and
Mack and Bank of America Citigroup they
were all regulated institution a huge
percentage of them of the bad loans came
out of companies that when fact were
regulated and were encouraged to do
subprime lending and we got the constant
it was a moral crusade it's interesting
people now Barney Frank and I the guys
at the dodd-frank bill they were the
huge advocates of this crazy lending the
time I talked to both of them we tried
to show them that it's going to end
badly and they just weren't interested
in it because it was immoral to go for
them we said well this ends badly for
the borrowers but no no this is the
right thing to do so it was a moral
persuasion and the influence down in the
trenches was dramatic and yes there were
a lot of crazy people that did super
stuff at the end of the cycle after the
bubble had already blown up thank you
[Applause]
thanks gene well well thank you it was a
very enjoyable evening and great debate
and again thanks for the opportunity to
be here and really do appreciate it and
you know I'm an economist I look at the
data I stick to the data and you know
the most telling statistic is the chart
I showed the madam mortgage debt that
the private-label securities market
accounted for in the late 90s and early
2000s was less than 10 percent by 2006
early 2007 at the peak of the bubble it
was over 20% at the same time is the
share of mortgage debt that went to the
private local securities market
increased the share of mortgage debt
that went to Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac
declined almost percentage point two
percentage point I mean I think that's
pretty clear who led the way here and
who is the principal culprit in causing
the financial crisis but let me just say
a couple things about the future and
what we can take away from this first
thing I'd say is I feel better about the
financial system post crisis because I
do think the regulatory oversight and
regulatory framework today is in a much
better place than it was 10 years ago
the system is highly capitalized very
liquid there's good risk management
their stress testing their portfolios
they're adopting accounting standards
that are more consistent with prudent
risk management I think the odds because
of this improvement in the regulatory
environment and oversight
the odds of a financial crisis on the
scale of what we experienced 10 years
ago now are very very low they're
unlikely to happen certainly not in my
lifetime having said that though I am an
economist and I can't end on a positive
note you know there are things to worry
about and when you think about the
financial system in my simplistic way
thinking about it there is the regulated
part of the system the system that Johns
Bank BB&T is in the banking system the
depository institutions they account for
about half of all the credit provided to
the economy the other half is the
so-called shadow financial system and
its shadow because it's not transparent
there's no light much less regulated and
there are things going on in the shadow
system that we need to watch and parts
of the shadow market that are as ill
defined as the subprime market was ten
years ago so this is going to be a
never-ending battle and we're going to
go back and forth about government and
private markets but that battle is not
over it's gonna miss something we're
gonna have to grapple with going forward
and if you really want to know what I'm
worried about
you'll have to ask me back for another
debate thank you
thank you for a very spirited debate we
now go into the final voting portion of
the evening again please go back into
your apps the financial crisis of 2008
was caused mainly by government induced
distortion of markets rather than caused
mainly by intrinsic market failure
please vote yes no or undecided on the
resolution okay 60.6% voted for the
resolution on the pre those sixty
percent that rose to seventy point eight
percent picked up ten point one percent
which points that's the number to beat
then no went from fifteen point seven to
seventeen to a nearly eighteen picked up
two and a quarter both gained votes but
the yes vote spoke more but gained more
John you got the tootsie roll
you
[Music]